e aí galera que assistiu planalto vocês
todo mundo tem um amigo que me paguem ou
pensa que imita alguém vai nascer mittal
civis andaime time foi mais atacar tk
dinheiro a pessoa na cabeça dela acha
que ela sabe time tá aqui pra vocês
algumas vozes que eu acho que eu sei
fazer
9 não ganhou rodas
ah
você não me conhece e ai que tudo em mim
em ok então vamos conversar estou muito
feliz e espero que com isso ninguém
precisa com lucas e lucros embora da
minha mãezinha
marina
e eu não sei cantar em inglês bem meu
céu meu pão de mel é meu bem querer ele
e daí meu saiu eu pude mais um erro meu
bem dele
curió taicang e de comida da vovó é isso
aí galera do reg é levado para cleiton
rasta fazendo a festa com a galera aqui
do povoado santo antônio há para aí ó
com certeza como é fácil o pleito rasta
vai fazer a galera de boxe é legal sobre
o cabeça de gelo a uma queda e janeiro
chama se chama ir embora
no entanto melo e meu nome não é jhonny
seu domingo eu estava dentro da minha
casa quando me dei conta que a fumaça
estava bem alta e pensei oh meu deus
será que deixe algo no fogo quando
percebi já estava tudo em chamas pensei
oh meu deus será que vou morrer quando
corri para o canto do quarto olhei para
a janela e avistei de roni
ela parecia muito nervosa quando ele
estava sentada olhei para ela e pensei
oh meu deus eu não queria estar no lugar
dela
foi então que jones saltou da janela me
colocou em seus braços fortes cheio de
músculos e veias e me levou para fora e
eu pensei oh meu deus é ou não vou
morrer e já com ele os braços eu pensei
oh meu deus eu salvei uma vida dá pra
acreditar
olha só a melody tenha gostado se você
tiver gostar de alguma dessas limitações
que gostei aqui embaixo na verdade mais
voltar lá no facebook você vê esse vídeo
em vídeo não sei que curte e marca um
amigo seu pêlo visitações e 18 o meu
show de humor em teresina piauí no
teresina raul ingressos na bilheteria do
teresina shopping no primeiro link da
descrição do vídeo muito obrigado por
existir esse vídeo até aqui se escreve
para não perder um vídeo toda vez que
tiver você vai saber
valeu r&b e pede é político tabucchi que
o protótipo picchu